ciao ragazzi sì lo so che sono le otto
del mattino ma tra due minuti lizza la
baby dance e piscina verità il giro
della trottola il salto del canguro e tu
che ci fai qui da sola ma lo sai che ci
sono un sacco di ragazzi che si sono
stati iscritti al torneo di beach 9 che
fai te ne prendi mito del mondo la mano
e la carretta
oltre a mano alla carta un movimento
sexy ma allora siete già pronte ma come
per cosa sta per iniziare la lezione di
acqua 105 minuti in piscina così
smaltite barbecue di ieri sera
[Musica]
siete pronti per la serata egiziana vi
voglio tutti belli come paraoli e mi
spiace validi gruppo sono finiti per
oggi sto scherzando tra cinque
nell'utilizzo zumba in spiaggia venite
con me e nonne mamme papà a londra le
buste murer ahi ahi como che lavatelo
d'ombre a sia sì mi mancherete davvero
tantissimo ragazzi
buon viaggio ciao